we are in the absolute final stretch of
the 2022 midterm elections things are
looking very very good for Republicans
right now and one of the absolutely most
interesting races in the country happens
to concern one of my absolute favorite
United States senators and that would be
Senator Mike Lee over in Utah good
strong conservative Senator who's facing
a little bit of a weird challenge
because he's running against well I
guess he is running against a Democrat
but he's running against a Democrat who
says he's a republican with the backing
of the Democrats and the
very liberal Republican other senator
from Utah is staying kind of neutral in
any way it's very very intricate and
bizarre Senator Lee thank you for coming
on the show
oh thanks for having me Michael so
senator
all sorts of crazy races to watch this
year Georgia Pennsylvania Arizona Nevada
all over the place
yours might be the strangest one
actually of all of them because I
thought look this is a a republican Year
Mike Lee has one of the best
conservative records in the United
States Senate in the United States
frankly as far as I'm concerned Utah is
a very good conservative State and yet
there's there's this weird fact you're
running against this guy Evan McMullen
who was the kind of never Trump
candidate from 2016 who some Democrats
gave a bunch of money to uh fruitlessly
and then he's now he's running for
Senate in Utah but the Democrats are
backing him and I I don't pretend to
know all of the intricacies how does the
race stand
here's where it stands look at this race
is much closer than it should be for the
simple reason that we've got an
independent who's telling Republicans he
still thinks like a republican he
actually calls himself a conservative
he's telling Democrats he'll vote like a
Democrat and the local media is
overwhelmingly liberal entirely liberal
in fact and so they cover it up for them
uh they don't actually make him talk
about issues and where he would stand on
things in fact the most substance he's
provided on how he would vote was
provided to the Utah Democratic party
while he was actively courting their
endorsement you see he went to them and
said don't run a Democrat because they
have a d after their name
I'll have an eye after my name but I'll
vote more or less how you want me to
vote and I can get elected more easily
than they can but let me tell you what I
stand for and he rattled off a whole
bunch of things where he stood with them
including the fact that he voted for Joe
Biden he campaigned for Joe Biden he
encourage others to do the same he
supports things like
hr1 S1 this bill that would take over
the authority to run Federal elections
strip the states of their authority to
impose voter ID requirements and
otherwise make it almost impossible for
any Republican ever to win an election
again
he also said that he would nuke the
filibuster for purposes of passing
hr-1s1 this is really dangerous stuff
but meanwhile the mainstream news media
in Utah which is to say the entire media
establishment in Utah save one or two
radio talk show hosts uh is backing this
guy helping this guy so yeah this race
is closer than a shipping it's uh it's
probably as close uh a general election
as we've had in quite a while for a U.S
Senate race in Utah wow it's not
surprising in a certain way because it
seems to me the only way the Democrats
have any hope of winning really anything
this year is through chicanery and this
is this is a great example of that kind
of chicanery I actually didn't know that
about mcmullen's support for you in your
very diplomatic very you know uh polite
Utah way or calling it hr1 and S1 a lot
of people call it the corrupt
politicians act this is just such a an
awful piece of legislation our mutual
friend Ted Cruz coined that term and I
think it's a it's a delightful and
accurate way of describing it yeah
absolutely and so to to to go in and
basically cut it secret Shady deal with
the Democrats and say look I'll pretend
to be a Republican or at least an
independent to get the Republicans to
vote for me but don't worry I'm going to
be a vote for you guys because I don't
really I don't really I'm not running on
policy or anything I'm just voting to to
give the Democrats political power just
like I was campaigning to elect Joe
Biden just like I was running to be a
spoiler against Donald Trump just like
just like this guy who kind of came out
of nowhere seems to continue to do you
know he's the Republican who just does
whatever the Democrats want it's it just
to me is so absolutely shady and I I
have to say I mean it seems to me
basically every single Senate Republican
supports you uh every conservative that
I know that I've spoken about it with
supports you
there is one Senator who's been kind of
quiet on the race I can't help but
notice
yeah uh there's one look I I'm very
grateful to have the support of
48 of my Senate Republican colleagues uh
there are 50 of us in total uh it's
implicit that I support my own candidacy
which would be weird if I didn't uh uh
there there's one outlier like my fellow
senator from Utah hasn't but look
um
I I'm just grateful that I've got the
support of all the others I mean look
Susan Collins and I don't agree on
everything you're talking but we don't
and she endorses me Lisa McCarthy does
as well
um so I'm grateful for their endorsement
I uh the door's always open uh to the
remaining Senator my colleague from Utah
uh if he decides he wants to get on
board in the meantime he said he's got
two friends in this race and wants to
stay out all right I guess that's his
prerogative his decision to make it
speaks volumes as far as I'm concerned
and I think really bolsters you're a
conservative bonifides as far as I'm
concerned as well so uh Senator Lee I I
know it's a close race and there are all
sorts of crazy things that could happen
between on Election Day I'm confident
you will be re-elected I'm not surprised
that the Democrats are doing everything
they can to get rid of you you have been
a big thorn in their side for many years
now so what happens once uh once the
Republicans retake the sen it you go
back to Washington DC what what do we
have to look forward to
well look I I hope and expect that we
will retake the majorities in both
houses of Congress the house looks like
pretty much a lock uh the Senate is
looking better every day you know with
some exceptions including my race here
and there
um but when we get back I I really do
think we'll be on a short Leash from the
American people with good reason uh
we'll be on a short leash in the sense
that they will expect us
to put an end uh to all of the nonsense
that Joe Biden is perpetrating on the
American people we won't be able to do
everything that we would like to do
because we still don't occupy the White
House but we can put an end to the worst
of the worst of what he's doing we can
put an end to you know bringing in four
trillion dollars last year in spending
seven uh that's not going to happen
under Republican watch I would hope that
we would also uh conduct real meaningful
oversight and get answers to all sorts
of questions about things that have
happened that shouldn't have happened to
the government over the last few years
from the humanitarian crisis on the
border uh to the fentanyl problem to
Tony fauci and uh well what appeared to
be blatant lies that he told under oath
uh I I look forward to each of those
things I look forward to figuring out
what happened in Afghanistan why we
boshed that so badly but again that is
another reason why this Race Matters
um my opponent has claimed that he won't
caucus with either party which means
that he really would be strengthening
the hand of the Democrats and weakening
the hand of Republicans if he were
elected so especially I mean if who
knows people are saying maybe the
Republicans will they could win up to 54
seats you know on Election Day those are
kind of the rosiest estimates but not so
long ago it was very unclear that the
Republicans would retake the Senate it
remains so and there's a very good
chance Republicans don't retake the
Senate and so a guy coming out there in
a very conservative State and saying I
will not caucus with the Republicans
could be the difference between Joe
Biden gets to do whatever he wants and
Joe Biden is stopped from instituting
his legislative agenda
no that's exactly right and in fact I I
recently discovered a tweet that my
opponent sent out on January 3rd 2021 on
the Eve literally of the uh Georgia uh
U.S Senate raised a dual U.S Senate race
um runoff
and he encouraged people to defeat the
two Republicans
to defeat them
because as he put it the Republican
party is Eddie I don't remember what
exactly said it was something like
irredeemably lost and corrupt or
something like that so he did his best
to disempower a republican majority then
and by the way that cost us at least
four trillion dollars in Reckless
inflationary spending uh thanks for that
Evan but we shouldn't do that again
but uh look he's making it close because
the media is giving him millions of
dollars in free media they never make
him answer anything he's raising uh
millions of dollars off of act blue the
Democratic donor Network
and he's got a Super PAC that is uh has
spent three or four million dollars on
attack ads on me so I've got to be able
to combat that so if any of your
listeners and viewers who want to
support my campaign they can do so at
leeforsenet.com and unlike Evan McMullen
this is not through act Blue I'm on
windbreather
I always think you know Senator Iris
think that you can judge a man by his
enemies you know and you can judge a man
by his friends and uh
I think you've got absolutely all the
right enemies and I think that uh Evan
McMullen has all of the wrong friends
and I I I you know I I just
the libs drive me crazy because the libs
have a terrible agenda and they cause
all sorts of Destruction in the country
but there's one group that I I have even
less respect for than the libs who were
destroying the country and that that
would be
the the deceitful people who pretend to
be conservative or Republican and then
all they ever do is the bidding of that
corrosive liberal establishment that is
destroying our our fiscal situation
opening up our borders you know tearing
the country apart and as far as I can
tell the only thing that your opponent
has done in political life
is that I can't idea he came onto the
scene in 2016. I mean I'm sure he had he
had a career before that but he came
onto the political scene in 2016.
that's all the guy has ever done and I
think we've really really got to be
aware of these deceitful people in
politics you I'm not just flattering you
I say it because it's an important race
and and because I mean it you have been
a real straight shooter you're a good
guy I know you personally the seat is
very important concern Utah is a
conservative state it would be insane
for Utah to have a a senator doing only
the bidding of the democratic party
would be absolutely awful and so Senator
I really wish you the best of luck in
the race I'm confident that you will win
it how else can people support you look
in addition to going to leave for
senate.com uh people who are online uh
communicating on Facebook on Twitter on
Instagram on any social media platform
uh can interact when they see comments
being made that don't make sense uh back
them up with conservative arguments call
out people call about people who are uh
praising my opponent just supposedly a
conservative hero
my opponent is rebranding himself still
as a conservative after getting the
Democratic nomination and convincing
them not to run a candidate he's now
calling himself a conservative uh only
he redefines conservative to mean he
likes to go on Hikes and he believes in
America and democracy he uh he actually
ran sort of to the right of Donald Trump
in 2016 because Donald Trump was
insufficiently committed to seeing Roe
versus Wade overturned and standing up
for for pro-life causes and uh been a
few months ago he went on MSNBC
and said that he's opposed to
overturning Roe versus Wade but he still
markets himself as pro-life only he's
redefined the term pro-life to mean that
he believes we should have more social
programs so um he's really good at
redefining things and I I frequently
want to tell him I don't think that word
means what you think it means sir uh
anyway uh I can use all the help I can
get in messaging and uh I really
appreciate you having me on your show
Senator my pleasure entirely I would
strongly encourage our Utah listeners to
go vote for the conservative in the race
not the cynical opportunistic Democrat
Senator thank you for coming on the show
thank you Michael
[Music]